- [Narrator] The forces of nature remain
the one thing that man cannot control.
Despite the comfort our
newfound capabilities
to predict inclement
weather have afforded us,
we are reminded time and again that
there are forces at work
beyond our understanding.
And as the clouds gather,
we cannot always predict
what will tumble out of them.
This October on Friday the 13th,
from an executive producer
of The Walking Dead
and an executive producer of The X-Files
comes six terrifying tales based
on the podcast phenomenon, Lore.
Until then, we offer you this short
film inspired by the series.
- My name is Rosemarie Sanders.
I am an earth science teacher.
So that means I know a thing
or two about the weather.
Having animals fall from the sky
has been documented on paper
going back to the 9th century.
It is disconcerting.
But some people take it catastrophically.
- [Narrator] New meaning
was given to the phrase
raining cats and dogs in June of 2009
when scattered showers
of frogs rained down
upon the residents of
Rakoczifalva in Hungary.
As stunned onlookers
grasped for an explanation,
the downpour ceased just as
abruptly as it had begun.
- Sometimes the frogs
have come down alive.
As they get turned in the
cloud and broken apart,
sometimes it's pieces of frogs
and sometimes they're frozen.
They were pulled very high
into this cumulonimbus cloud.
It's very cold at the top of the cloud
and they will freeze and drop suddenly.
In the heat of the summer,
you're more prone to have
this cumulonimbus cloud developing.
A waterspout can touch down over a pond
and because frogs are
very lightweight animals,
they can be pulled into the cloud itself.
- [Narrator] The same year, a
rainfall of hundreds of fish
bombarded residents of
Lajamanu, Australia,
326 miles from the nearest river.
Even today, the scientific
community has yet to reach
consensus on an explanation
for the phenomenon.
- Honestly, it would depend
on the size of the animal.
It would also depend on the
strength of the system itself.
And it can fall great distance
from where it was first
picked up because the
cloud would be traveling.
When you see in reports in the mid-west,
you can get softball-sized hail stones.
They weigh a lot more than a frog.
Now a lot of times frogs or
fish raining from the sky
is often seen as a sign from God
or an upset of the natural world.
- [Narrator] The Old Testament is filled
with such examples of
a vengeful God's wrath.
In the book of Exodus, a
plague of frogs rained down
upon the people of Egypt as punishment
for Pharaoh's refusal
to free the Israelites.
Are the raining animals an
environmental disruption
to be explained by
further scientific study
or are these modern day plagues,
a warning that the end of days is near?
- It can be frogs, it can
be fish and it can be birds.
And any anomaly in the natural
world can be very disruptive.
Without sounding trite,
I would say watch your step.